this is a production of cornell
university
thank you margaret for the introduction
and thanks for the invitation for this
talk
um so yes i'm i'm calling in from iced
austria
in more exciting times i could have
maybe visited cornell but now it's uh
you have to do with the background
of my fake background actually and then
what you see on the slide so
ist austria is a multi-disciplinary
institute
it's doing pretty good on the on the
world ranking but that's not
what i want to brag about um it's
multidisciplinary what makes it very
interesting
and there's actually only two plant
groups at the moment which is
my group and then eva benkova who works
on cytokinin
group so it uses group and evas group
and in 2022 there will be
an extra plant group but that will be on
epigenetics
so the institute is most known for the
interactions between other disciplines
so then what i would like to talk to you
about today
is the rapid responses in um root growth
and um that's actually exciting research
um what has been playing the whole time
in my background here is this
rapidly growing root well it's actually
just a normally growing route
but it is actually a demonstration of
what we have changed how we can image
roots
live and what technology we have done to
do that i will introduce
a bit later on so we can actually live
see how a root grows
and whether it interacts with other
roots like in this case or
whatever other thing that it would come
across so
i divided the this presentation
in um two main
subjects as migrant sets i have actually
two papers under revision
i made this kind of timeline that you
will see in the top
of all my slides so you can follow where
you are and if you would have um
questions please then type them in the
chat box i will try to handle them at
the end
or in the student meeting afterwards so
in the divisions you can see i will give
a short introduction
on auxin then as i said we have exciting
technology and then it will move on into
the things that we identified so there
will be
uh ahas which i will tell you what these
are and then there will be a part of
myosin and then everything highlighted
will always show you where we are so i
hope it's easy to follow
so auxin i don't know whether it needs a
big introduction but it was actually the
first
discovered plant hormone and that is
because it has a very strong
growth effect like almost all the
developmental plant steps are actually
affected by auxin but
the phototropic and the gravitropic
growth are mainly
regulated by auxin and because of this
phototropism which was a clear thing
already in the 1800s people
discovered that there was actually one
molecule
or a family of molecules responsible for
this that was
transported in a plant that could be
leaking
out of the collectible tip which then
if you would put the agar block in which
it the hormone had leaked
again on the coleoptile it would still
do the same thing so
the coleoptile that would sense light
would grow towards the light and that's
still the case if you replace it by
a block of acre that just contains
something and
what is already a long time established
is that this
bending is because of this molecule
auxin and it's actually auxin that gets
redirected so you have it in the
beginning symmetrically distributed
everywhere throughout your system
but depending on an external influence
you would have it
asymmetrically being redistributed and
then you had to have
cell elongation happening so this is
what i said
1813 oxen got his name and auxin comes
from the greek oxen
so it's actually to grow and that's
where it got its name from
most of the time it's made in a plant
based from the amino acid
tryptophan but there's actually um quite
some pathways known that don't involve
the amino acid
defined as well it's just the major
pathway is keep the fundament
um it's not unique to plants you can
also find it in
a green algae or at least the some of
the biosynthetic enzymes are also
present in green alky
so that's the lowest class where you can
find it but even
some bacteria and mostly soil bacteria
have auxins as well
endogenously in a plant you would find
this molecule most
and that is called triangle endolatry
acetic acid
indole-3-acetic acid sorry and that one
is found most but there's actually these
other
three that depending on the species you
can determine as well
or it has auxin effects as well
besides from this endogenic auxin you
have
a lot of synthetic auxins and i'm
introducing them because in this
presentation i will both use naa which
is one of the synthetic ones nia
so that's why i'm introducing this
what auxin is most uniquely known for is
not just that it affects most of the
growth
responses in a plant but that it is
transported uniquely
it's i think the only hormone that is
actually
between cells in a uni-directionally
weight transported
so what is happening in if you look at
on the plant scale you have actually
auxin being produced in the
shoot applications and leaves also in
the in the buds
from there it's loaded into the general
transport pathway so it goes into the
flowing
down towards the roots where it mostly
would act
or down towards bugs that it's
inhibiting from outgrowth so it's
transported downwards
general transport pathway and then when
it comes at the tip of the route
there's this fountain pathway back now
all of this depends on actually
intracellular
specific transport of oxygen otherwise
you would never be able to go
back up from the top and that is
depicted here
so what happens with this molecule in
the apoplast which is
slightly acidic you have the molecule
charged and that actually can enter
into a plant cell through diffusion so
just passively going in
or through influx carriers they are
known we know
what these are then something is
happening inside of the cell
no one exactly knows what yet but
what is happening to the molecule is
that it um definitely becomes
charged so this dissociates from a
proton and it will need to get out of
the cell it will need active transport
and for that
there's actually a big family of efflux
carriers known they are called pin
transporters
and this is a where my boss here
became famous uh with so here's the
discovery of the pins or the lord of the
pins
um and these pin carriers is actually
what makes
auxin transport uniquely unidirectional
because
they are not just randomly placed within
a cell they very often go to a specific
location
as you can see here so these images are
actually from
immuno localization which means that you
are not
looking at the gfp but at the endogenous
protein
so you use an antibody against a protein
that then you can visualize using a
secondary
protein so this is the the normal
localization
within a root of pin one and it's
basically in all the cells
and then if we would look at pen two
another pin
that is actually together with pin one
responsible for this
fountain transport you see that because
of this localization in other cell
layers epically
you can actually establish this fountain
so
as said this is unique what is then also
important to know is that
auxin signaling is known forever as well
um and since the 80s people started to
temporarily
dissect this process and the closest or
the fastest responses that people have
within the signaling pathway is within
two to three minutes you have actually
sour genes going up
growth however is delayed and it happens
approximately 10 to 20 minutes after you
apply the auxin
so there's actually a delay in those
things so primarily it was thought that
auxin regulates transcription
and that happens through this it's the
simplest cartoon that i could find
is actually a funny one because what you
have is you have receptors
within a plant a signal of course would
be auxin
and when auxin binds to the receptor it
actually
attracts within its complex a
co-receptor um
and that one thereby gets um
ubiquitinulated
it gets targeted for degradation in the
proteasome
and it relieves this activator so
suddenly they can be active and then
transcription of proteins can happen so
this is
how it looks a bit more complicated and
more interestingly
this is happening in the nucleus of the
cell so you have these
receptors which are waiting for the
signal whenever auxin is coming which is
this green molecule
it attracts these small repressors which
are called aux ias
within the complex they get
ubiquitinated they get degraded and the
arcs are able to
initiate transcription so this is what's
happening
within the nucleus however things are
already known for a while
that are faster and they are also aux
mediated for example there is the
recycling of these
and i just introduced them to you these
spin exporters
from the membrane they get recycled and
back to the membrane and
that is also a process that is affected
by auxin itself
so that is a faster process that most
likely does not
involve transcription then there's also
another possible pathway that involves a
transmembrane kinase
and that one also might regulate
transcription differently
and then lastly and recent work has
shown that
what was thought to be a purely nuclear
signaling pathway with these
efbs residing in the nucleus is probably
not entirely true because within the
family you actually have members like
this
afb1 that are cytoplasmic one so you
probably also have receptors within the
cytoplasm
so if you would look at a signaling
pathway in a logic way what would be
is and especially as i told you auxin is
unidirectionally transported within
cells and comes from the able plus
from without from outside of the cell if
you would look then at a signaling
pathway
you would actually have a hormone from
outside
binding to a receptor that potentially
should be residing within the plasma
membrane and then
generates a signal transaction within
the cell so
this is what you would expect what i
just explained that we know from auxin
signaling
is nothing like this because we don't
know how
this part happens we don't know what
happens within the apoplast
within the cell membrane we only knows
what happens with the receptors
in the nucleus itself so there's
actually
a long going um discussion
and even questions being asked for a
long time already whether there would
also be an apoplastic auxin signaling
pathway that then mediates
fast signaling and there i have to
touch a controversial subject within the
auxin
field because in the beginning of 1980s
a protein was found and it's called
auxin binding protein
and that protein was found to bind with
high affinity to auxin
and it was found to be residing in the
endoplasmic reticulum
but also in the apoclast um
it is controversial because at some
point the mutants
ended this protein didn't were not what
they were supposed to be so they also
had a mutant in the neighboring gene
so all the phenotypes were not correct
but we still do think that
maybe there is an extracellular pathway
mediated by abp1 because that protein is
there and it has eye affinity to uh
to auxin and then probably interacting
with
um loose enrich repeats receptor-like
kinase core receptor complexes
whereby it's mediating intracellular
effects for example rob rick
signaling is shown to be affected by a
pathway like this
and it's important for pin
internalization so again these pins come
back so these transport molecules they
get internalized to be recycled
back to the plasma membrane so for that
um
auxin has an effect on that pathway and
that is a fast pathway it's
not involving the nuclear
transcriptional
signaling that we know and then secondly
um because here it's still vague it's
still it just tests loose enrich repeat
receptor-like kinases
secondly and recently there has been a
paper that
actually gives a name to one of these
potential core receptors
it's a transmembrane kinase one tmk1
and in the in the
closed application it's a very important
protein
because when actually the hook has to
open or it is actually deregulating the
opening of the hook
then there's a auxin signaling
triggering this tmk and the kinase is
actually
very weird one because it releases its
kinase domain which goes to the nucleus
their phosphorylates um
aux ias the repressors that i talked for
before
and then make sure that differential
growth can happen
so yes potentially there is an
apoplastic signaling pathway
but we don't know really what is going
on yet
then as i said we have things happening
within three minutes transcriptionally
but
what we actually do see is that for
example a calcium spike upon auxin
happens within a minute which is much
faster than the three minutes that
cannot rely on transcription
there's other things like growth
inhibition that happens very fast as
well i will show you that later so we
needed to develop
microscope uh techniques or
microscopical techniques
to be able to actually visualize what is
happening very fast upon
auxin treatment and in
our group we have this unix system that
combines a vertical microscope with a
microfluidic system
and the vertical microscope i will show
you later is just a flipped microscope
so it allows you to image plants within
their physiological conditions so the
root goes down and the shoot goes up
but it is also combined with a automated
tip tracking system so we don't have to
measure growth as such
what is happening is that in a matlab
based script
we actually determine what the position
shift is between
time point zero and time point one time
point one and time point two and based
on these two calculations we calculate
where the window has to shift
and you have already seen a result of
that because that's why in my intro
in my first slide i can image this route
growing the whole frame
because this is high confocal microscopy
imaging
without having to change the microscope
so this is all happening automatically
the system calculates how much it should
shift and it shifts as well
based on the coordinates of the shifts
we can then calculate
the the growth rate so it's actually
very convenient for us
and this is how it looks like so we have
actually really literally flipped the
microscope with 19 degrees
we provided some extra support so that
you can actually
lean into it when you have the screen
because you have to stand at this
microscope
and then you have at the stage you
actually have just physiologically as i
said the roots growing down and you can
image these
over time so we um
we can use confocal lenses for this
however any high numerical aperture
confocal lens would require an immersion
solution
and as we have flipped everything
anything you would apply here would drip
off as well so we are kind of
limited to expensive
uh dry objective like a 40x objective so
we can't really go into
um like cytoskeleton details in this
system but we can do very good imaging
and then i said we do a combination of
things so we also
um to be able to visualize very fast
changes and treatments we also have
developed this microfluidic system
and it's actually just the polymer in
which we
have channels left out and the channels
are super low volume which means that if
you want to change treatments
it goes very far fast and it's actually
controlled by an airtight valve
so you have a valve that will close when
you put air through it and then
when it opens you have the medium
streaming through um
this allows us to image eight roots at
the same time and all individually treat
them or don't treat them so this is how
it looks within the channel the root is
nicely there
and the system works very well
but why is this all important like every
single one person that has worked with
auxin knows that auxin is actually
inhibiting the root like you see a
normal seedling
at four days looks like this an auxin
grown seedling has a very tiny root and
has more root hairs
this is how it looks like in our root
imaging system so what we do is actually
we have this root growing
in these microfluidics channels and
every time you see
you see the background turning uh pink
that's when we have auxin
in presence of the root and you kindly
see it because it's actually growing
stops growing growing and it stops
growing so if you would
plot that now in in frames instead of
looking at a movie you would actually
see
it's standardly growing it's a generally
growing and then when you apply the
auxin it's inhibited
and when you wash it out again it's
growing again so this allows us to
really image root growth
and when we saw this we knew that we had
the system ready to really visualize
very fast responses
because what we now can do we can
actually look at
what is responsible for auxin to do this
root growth inhibition
and that's the first the first part of
my my results then
what we did is we looked at
responses within a plant that would
correlate with this root growth
inhibition so we looked at
are the microtubules affected well they
were not or at least not within the same
time frame as we saw the root growth
stopping
so probably they were not the cause for
any of the auxin effects of the fast
austin effect we saw we looked at
vacuolar
structure that was not affected either
but then
we shifted to this we actually
and that's also because of a long
lasting hypothesis that i will come back
to later as well
we actually looked at what is happening
with the ph
around these cells that are stopping to
grow so
for that within our system of the
microfluidics we just had to add one
more dye
and it's a ratiomatic ph indicator so
it's it's a dye that you just can
visualize
and with that dye you can actually see
what is happening in the epiplus
of cells so same
idea however the frames are now within
30 seconds of each other
so what you would see is 30 seconds 30
seconds 30 seconds nothing is happening
at here at time point zero we apply the
auxin
and then you suddenly see that the color
shifts
which means in our case that the ph is
increasing
so we actually have almost immediately
an alkalinization so it's getting more
basic
in the able plus of the cells and if you
would quantify that you actually have
a super nice correlation graph between
growth inhibition that is in black
and then the ph that goes up within the
roots
so we think that we have found
alkalinization to be the cause for this
rapid root growth inhibition
and then we dug deeper into this no
because we we had a
causative or correlative effect at least
so what we then did was
can we mimic this by instead of doing
auxin can we already change the ph in
the external medium of our roots and
then see what is happening
and actually that worked very nicely
because when we what we do then is we
have
our normal medium that is uh ph 5.8
when we exchange that for a more iconic
meat alkali
alkaline medium of ph 6.15 the root
stops growing
and it really takes back its growth when
you when you switch it
on the uh the opposite is also true when
you
exchange your medium for an even more
acidic medium
you speed up the growth of the roots so
this was pretty cool because we
really could show that alkalinization of
this apoplast
was sufficient to inhibit root growth
inhibition and
this this is what what we needed we
needed a causal effect
so this also is cool because what i said
ph and apoplastic ph more specifically
makes sense because i think it's from
1940s
there was already this acid growth
theory going on
that involves ph changes within
the apoplast because you will need a
lower ph
that activate enzymes to allow your cell
wall to be more flexible
so what is actually happening is that
what is said in this theory is that
auxin stimulates
um proton pumps that pump out protons
into the cell wall where enzymes get
activated the cell wall is more
flexible which then would allow
water uptake and other iron uptake that
will make the cell swells and swelling
means growing so proton pumps play this
play an essential role in this model and
there is a ph effect as well in this
model
um so what we did was well actually we
do see this alkalinization but do we
really see that
when we check protons as well so
therefore we
actually took advantage of a reporter
line that is
it's a genetically encoded reporter line
so it's fused to um
yeah what is it again it's a
it's a membrane anchored uh
protein element so where you fuse a
ratio metric again
die too so it's a fluorometric dye that
you can then use so
you can image this so what is happening
this is what i just showed you
slide before where you have the
correlation between apoplastic ph
and growth but inside of the cell where
we have this
genetically encoded marker then inside
of the cell we don't see that at all we
actually see
the growth is inhibited but also the ph
goes acid more acidic so yes we have
actually something that makes sense
because we have
more alkaline apoplastic ph
and more acidic and intercellular ph
and that makes sense so that would also
mean that there is
a change in the net proton fluxes within
those cells
and we have a collaborator that manages
to measure
proton fluxes with non-invasive
microelectrodes and actually he could
confirm that there's a net increase of
the influx of protons in the cells
now you might start questioning this no
because i say
proton influx but this is all based on
growth
where you have proton efflux where that
happens
now you have to remember what we are
looking at is the root
in the root what is happening is that
auxin inhibits growths
this is completely in contrast with what
is happening and known and described
much more
in the shoot where auxin is actually
enhancing growth so
in the shoot and in all these coleoptile
experiments
where auxin accumulates that's where you
have more cell elongation so that's
where you have more growth in the root
we
observe completely the opposite so now
we had these fast responses that we
could correlate with ph and growth
but things still look too fast and
what is actually happening in the animal
field is that for fast responses
very often phosphorylate or phospho
[Music]
yeah actually phosphor relation
responses are responsible for the fast
response so what we could do was
and that was actually a lot of my input
is
why didn't we do an oxen treatment in
the root specifically and then go over a
very fast phosphoproteomic research
which would mean that um we isolate root
tips
we and we filter them so this is just
filter-assisted peptides doesn't really
matter what it means so we we get
peptides from these roots we enrich the
peptides
and then we throw them over titanium
beads
that will specifically enrich phosphor
peptides if we then
analyze these phosphopeptides through
a bit of a intensive
software packages then you actually
would have
specifically phosphorylated items within
very short time frame of auxin treatment
and i say very short it's actually two
minutes because physically i'm not able
to cut
root tips faster than two minutes to
have enough material to actually do a
mass spec
proteomics approach so it's two minutes
i probably
if i would be faster and the technology
would be more sensitive could do shorter
but
it's two minutes what i have now um so
what we have then actually
is we have a very significant
differential set of proteins most of the
ones in auxin treatments are actually
hyperphosphorylated
so it would be cool to dig into this and
find out what is happening there
but what we thought of was as the auxin
field is so well known we should take
advantage of what is known
and for that i have these two parts here
we actually took advantage of the fact
that there is a known
antioxidant which is called poia so it's
spelled like this and if this poi is
within the receptors so the nuclear tear
receptors
then the core receptor cannot bind to it
so in this case you would have something
binding to the receptor but not
stimulate the downstream signaling so
it's an antioxidant
and then there's a second
invention and that's an orthogonal or
engineered
receptor pair in which you actually have
an
engineered concave there receptor so
it's this receptor the normal one that
is just modified a little bit in a few
amino acids
in order for it not to fit normal auxin
anymore it fits only this
companion the convex ia auxin
and this convex ia does not fit at all
in the normal
terraceptor so by doing this pair you
actually specifically
can induce what is happening downstream
of tier one
i'm saying ter1 specifically because we
don't know whether the other
receptors might be binding it a little
bit so
that means i did also the phosphor
proteomics of
an convex iaea in the concave receptor
and i did it also in the poi
and also already here you can see that
there's different responses there's much
more hypophosphorylation
in these two treatments than there is in
the auxin by itself
and if you then look at this you really
see that
there's a lot of proteins that are
uniquely affected by
auxin and not by the other components
which could
indicate that we are here really
identifying items
or elements that are independent of the
known signaling pathway so we have
potentially a very interesting new set
of data here
and then what we also did was we
overlapped our set of
phosphorylated proteins with a published
phosphoprotein dataset that is actually
at two hours of treatment
and there you see that we are also
hitting a very unique
fast response so this approach
gave us potentially very interesting
things and
um then to go into the real interesting
results is we we really had
uh differentially phosphorylated targets
that would make sense with
the fast growth response because we had
aha proteins or
proton atpases as a target of this
um
hyperphosphorylated phosphoproteomics
approach and what are these
proton pumps they pump protons as i said
outside to the cells in arbelopsis
there's 12 of them
but aha one and two are most abundant
and highly expressed in different
tissues they are rather essential for
bond development
and they really make sure that you build
this proton motive force
which establishes or maintains the the
membrane potential and actually then
affects all
uptake and exchange within a plant and
they
work like this so in an inhibited state
they don't do anything
but when they are phosphorylated there's
actually interaction possible with 1433
proteins and
there's atp hydrolysis happening and
then the proton can
actually be exchanged so they are
interested and related to ph
it was not something new what we found i
mean
within the stems and hypocotyls what i
said before
it is known that auxin has an effect on
the activation of proton pumps but you
have to remember i mean this is within a
stem i said already there oxen does the
opposite effect
and it's also um no one there could cut
it down into our time frame so
everything was
later much later than what we did so
what would be the mechanism of these in
the hypocotyl where they are known
to work again i come back to this acid
growth theory so i don't really have to
tell you what
is happening here anymore protons go out
when the proton pumps are activated
phosphorylated and actually the pathway
is known in the hypocotyl
it is through the sour genes which are
the first ones coming up
um when you have the tip pathway
happening so these are transcriptionally
coming up
two to three minutes after the nuclear
pathway is activated
and the source inhibits a phosphatase
the phosphatase is then
not removing the phosphate groups
anymore the proton remains active and
it's pumping out
however if you see that in a schematic
view
there is a big part missing because if
you have a phosphatase there should also
be a kinase
the kinase that is actually actively
phosphorylating the protein of interest
as well
and that even in the hypocotyl where
much more research was done no one knew
which kinase it could be
um so as i said auxin induces hypocotyl
growth
acidification and in the root does the
opposite and there it does
alkalinization so
what we assumed was maybe the mechanism
is
maintained and it just works oppositely
in the root
so as i said we had this phosphorylation
of ahas
from the the mass specs data set which
you see clearly here
we had it nicely significantly
phosphorylated and we have it
consistently in all our sets that we do
and we actually also see a slightly
increased hydraulic activity which means
atp
aces are really working so they are
really pumping it's not just that it's
active
that is phosphorylated it's also
activated so that was very nice we have
this activation of the proton pumps
and we could also in a very ugly blot
but we can nicely confirm
that we actually have more
phosphorylation
of the activations the known activation
side of these phosphorus
these proton pumps so what you see here
is
no effect on the general protein level
but a clear increase
over time of the phosphorylated site so
that is nice it's for aha too that we
have this
phospho-specific antibody so this is a
easy western blood confirmation
but as i said we have this
alkalinization happening so the ph
increases but at the same time we have a
proton pump
being activated as well which actually
would mean that you have
acidification going on and you can
actually visualize that with this
bromocrysol blue it's it's very ugly but
when it turns
yellow there's actually protons being
pumped out of the root so it's in your
medium
so your medium changes ph which means
there's acidification going on too
and that means that probably we are
faced with two antagonistic pathways
that are both present at the same time
and they
will balance each other out to allow for
flexible responses
whatever is necessary at which time and
that makes sense in case of root growth
so if we want to gain more insight in
this antagonistic function we could
actually
chemically activate the proton pumps by
using a fungal toxin it's called
physicoxen
that stabilizes the interaction with the
1433 proteins and it would lead
immediately to a little bit of a drop
of the of the ph which means we we
activate the proton pumps
we see a drop in the ph acidification
that makes sense
and a promotion of the root code so
simultaneously we see a
promotion of the root crowd so it looks
like you really do have two separate
things
like when you activate the proton pumps
separately from the auxin you do see
acidification
and then we have the other thing going
on is it's a bit tricky because in the
proton pumps you have
12 of them as i said so there's a lot of
redundancy within the family
mutants are not so easy they are lethal
very often so the moment you combine one
and two
there's nothing happening anymore they
you don't have fertile seeds anymore
um so what we did was we have a
um an serna targeting um
four of the ahas but specifically
expressed from a root specific promoter
so we express it under the promoter of
pin 2 which we know that that's
in the root very nicely expressed and in
the external
cells of the roots which also make sense
for the responses of the root
growth and then from that promoter we
actually can reduce
the aha expression so what we see in
those mutants is we see actually that
that mutant is
hypersensitive to auxin
when you add it so there's more
alkalinization in this mutant so higher
values here than there is in the wild
type and there's
less growth in it so it's hypersensitive
if you add it and it's also
hypersensitive if you would
grow it on a concentration range of
oxygen you always see
more response to ox in low
concentrations than it would
in wild type which is the black graph or
in an over
it's a conservatively over active aha
one mutant is called open stomata tree
and this one is always open proton
points are always active protein pumps
there you have a reduced sensitivity
so again this this kind of makes sense
that we have
auxin-mediated activation and that is
antagonizing the oxygen-induced
alkalinization because this would mean
that we have
alkalization going on and then this
is back to what is actually responsible
for this there is an ongoing discussion
within the field
that it's probably not an afb signaling
and it's probably or maybe this a abp1
tmk1 pathway now there could be indeed a
role for tmp1 as i said before
and tmk1 belongs to a family of four so
there's four of them
and what i had been doing was i grew um
i think a thousand plates of roots
of a tmk-1 gfp line
and i looked whether i could find things
that i can co-purify with this so you
actually can do a
co-immuno precipitation assay followed
by a mass spec
and you just do the proteomics of
everything that you find that is
co-purified with your protein of
interest nicely enough i had
plasma membrane proteins so i was really
having something that had to do with
transmembrane kinase so plasma membrane
protein
and my fourth hit here were ahas
which made me really think like if i
have an interaction between
tmk and aha then maybe i have in my
hands the
unknown kinase because we have a
transmembrane kinase
that is interacting with it i just did a
few
implant experiments to really show that
i have them
interacting together one of them is this
um
bi molecular fluorescence essay so bfc
what you do there is you have either one
construct
with a split yfp the other construct
with the other side of the yfp if they
come together you actually have
reconstituted yfp
what i have to say is it's hyper ugly
but
that is because when we over express tmk
in tobacco plants
the plants shrink the cells shrink the
plant the leaves will
plants really don't like this uh this
protein being overexpressed
but i then did to overcome this
transient and and weird system in
tobacco i had stable lines
of tmk and aha and if i reciprocally
pulled down my target so either tmk here
or aha here
then i could actually detect the
opposite partner so i could detect ahas
in my tmk sample and i could detect
tmk in my aha sample so it's a
confirmation that they were interacting
in plant as well
and then i also always blot with this uh
specific phosphorylation antibody and i
see
that auxin still has an effect in both
of the cases
so then i really wanted to show that we
really do
need the mk1 for this phosphorylation of
ahas
and i did an uh phospho proteomics assay
again
but now in the tmk1 newton background
and i see
i saw that every single phosphoside that
we have
in aha proteins is downregulated so
normally would have a phosphorylation
level of one to be normal
these are all lower than one so every
fossil site is downregulated that i find
so there's hypophosphorylation of ahas
in the tmk mutant background
and this is uh my messiest slide i'm
really sorry for that but
what we do also do is we um we check
whether we still have this
induced phosphorylation in the mutant
background so in the tmk single mutant
we don't really see it anymore so
significantly so there's a really
increase in phosphorylation here
and there's far less we think in in this
one it goes better when you use double
mutants
so the moment you go in a tmk13 mutant
you really lose the
the phosphorylation induction and the
tmk14 mutant which is a very strong
dwarfed mutant has completely no
phosphorylation anymore of the of the
ahas so it really
does show that um you do need a tm case
to be um phosphorylating this ahas
and then if you would do it in a
activity assay the hydrolysis is the
same because ahas do need
atp then you actually see that only in
colombia
you have this induction of hydrolysis
this increased activity
you missed that in all the tmk mutants
so interesting we had
really shown that tmk was the kinase
responsible
and then we have actually a whole
theory that there's these two
antagonistic pathways
we have a lot of proof that we might
need for half of the pathway that
they're still
even though there is no known
transcriptional response that goes as
fast as what we see
so we think that this side is
so that's a under investigation now
people are really interested in this
inga can you can you repeat the last
sentence there
it just froze for a second
okay is it better now
okay so we we have a lot of indications
that we do need
their pathway for our responses but
probably not transcriptional
because it's too fast you cannot have
transcription going on faster than three
minutes
so this is under investigation the group
is very interested in this
and then we have this separate pathway
that probably involves an auxin
interaction with tmk
abp1 even though that's also a paper
that will come soon
because i investigated whether tmk could
be the receptor for auxin
by itself without need of abp1 but it
doesn't seem to be the case sadly enough
um but then actually you have this
pathway that
would inhibit the
epiplastic ph and then by by this
balance between the two you actually can
regulate growth so this is a
the first paper we have i think it's
interesting but we'll see where it gets
then the second one we have stems from
the same phosphoproteomic dataset
what we also found in there was actually
a very fast
phosphorylation of myosin 11k
and that is a motor protein it has a
actin binding capacity
and it's presumably involved in andro
endomembrane vesicular transport
so why is this interesting and that's
because of this
i mean i go back to this slide very fast
but it is because what i said
thin transporters and the localization
of them is essential for the whole
transport of auxin within a plant
and the localization is determined
very often by the recycling of them so
they go from
inside of the cell there's some
signaling that tells them yes you have
to go back to your basal localization or
there's some signal that says
wait wait we need more oxygen to the
lateral neighbor so you go to your
lateral side
so that is the recycling really
determines what is happening
and that's why myosin proteins are
potentially interesting as well
so i found them phosphorylated
in response to ia treatment as you see
here
so nicely phosphorylated less in my mock
more nia
and i didn't see so much effect of my
treatments my other treatments remember
these were the
showing whether it's tear dependent or
not treatments the effect is there a
little bit but it's far less significant
which made me think maybe this is very
interesting because i finally have
something
that is fully terr independent which
would mean that you have a
completely novel signaling um
we can confirm the phosphorylation of of
this myosin
k protein in something that is called
fostec
western blots in those western blots you
have actually
a molecule that is interacted with
phosphorylated proteins
in a normal blood a protein that is
phosphorylated you don't see
it would run in one line but in a
phosphate blot you actually separate
the phosphorylated moieties from the
non-phosphorylated moiety so
you actually have a multiple bands the
only problem is
the the gels very often run smiley and
ugly
but this is considered phosphorylation
not so we do see if you would quantify
the ratio between non-phosphorylated and
phosphorylated the phosphorylation as
well
and then within the myosin 11 family
there's actually one member that is also
very highly expressed within the root
it's the 11f member and that one
has actually very similar defects if you
would look at what it does to to the
plant growth
so from now on i will not just talk
about myosin
k but i will also talk about myosin f we
have double mutants from now
so how do we then uh determine whether
there is
defects in in pin trafficking or
localization
there's a few experiments you can do and
i know also this has been
contravention controversial since our
most recent publication because you have
a
toxin it's called brefolding a
it's actually an inhibitor of arf gafs
which are very important in vesicular
trafficking
and when you use this one you will
actually see that bin1 starts
accumulating in bodies so
um why did i in beginning stress that we
are able to do immuno localization
that's because of this
so here what we do as well is we we
visualize bin
in plants without having a fluorescent
pin targeted there we are really
visualizing it through the endogenous
antibody
so what you have what's happening is
that when you treat a plant with
bfa you actually start seeing that
there's trafficking going on
however the trafficking is blocked at
some point
and there's accumulation in these blobs
and it's called bfa compartments or bfa
bodies
so this is just a drug that can show you
that pins are indeed
being trafficked so what you then do is
if you trade the plants
with pfa and auxin you actually see
something very cool
and that is that there's certainly far
less of these bfa bodies
which means that auxin interferes with
his own
recycling and that's what i said in this
first slide
that is a known thing um it's visualized
by an artificial drug but it's it's kind
of cool
another way to visualize this is by
using fm 464.
it's a dye that that internalizes and
binds to
membrane structures so you would see it
in endosomes as well
so that's why in the wild type treated
with this dye you see nicely endosome
compartments so you see the dye there
but if you inhibit trafficking by having
ox in there then you have
less of these endosome compartments what
we then did is
you already don't see any of these
bfa bodies in the myosin double mutant
and you see far less of the the fm
internalization
in the myosin the one newton two so it
really looks like that auxin is
interfering
um with its own transport and that is
going
through the myosin proteins so the
myosin mutant that doesn't have them
is really required for the trafficking
we then did the same thing but what we
did now is
instead of just using myosin mutant we
made
a myosin phospho-deficient mutant which
means we knew exactly which site was
uh auxin responsible in the from the
phosphoproteomics
and we mutated that side so if you do
that you can actually mute it a
serine amino acid to an alanine amino
acid
and alanine will not get phosphorylated
it it doesn't have any spots to get a
phosphogroup
attached to it and what we did see in
that group in that
both in f and k mutant is that there's
certainly no bfa effect
and no na effect anymore so suddenly
everything was gone
also for the fm uptake so certainly in
these phospho-deficient
mutants there was no effect anymore so
it really does seem that this auxin
triggered phosphorylation is crucial for
the function of the myosin as well
and it's crucial for pen trafficking now
as i said we we look at two things that
are
a bit artificial so we have a
couple of better ways to look at pin
trafficking and trafficking in general
with a more physiologically relevant
output for example one of them is the
as i said the basal two lateral
relocalization
of pins that happens in a route when you
treat it with this
artificial auxin na when you have too
much of that auxin
the the root decides that it should get
rid of this auxin and it should do
something to the pin proteins
so again these are these
immunologicalization images
in a mock treated seedling you do see
the
pin one made mainly on the basal site
on the bottom of the cells but in the na
treated it goes to the interlateral side
so
it pushes the oxygen into the main
vascular stream to get rid of it
that is not happening as much in the
myosin mutant
and it's also not happening anymore in
when we have the phosphodeficient mutant
so again we we show that
you really do need this myosin
phosphorylation to have normal pain
responses
and as i was speaking about more
physiologically relevant responses
um the chute grows up we all know that
three faces with his leaves uh to the
sky
and the root goes to into the soil so a
hypocotyl
which is on the seedling level the shoot
does also do that so
when you switch a plant so you actually
are teasing a plant and you you give it
a turn of 90 degrees and suddenly make
the hypocotyl face the new gravity
response
the the hypocotyl will actually start
bending upwards
this also depends of pin proteins
because it's it are the pins that
result in this asymmetric oxygen
distribution that allows this side to
elongate and the inner side
not to elongate but at some point when
actually a
90 degree bending is reached this
hypocotyl should also stop
bending and that also again is
because the pins re-establish polarity
again so what is actually happening in
the myosin mutants is that they are
not stopping when they are supposed to
solve so they are delayed which means
they are hyper bending
so if you would measure their angle it's
always much more than it would
normally be in in seedlings and you can
also see that here they bend faster
and they go to a bigger angle than they
that they should have
so there really is a pin 3
reestablishment problem
the pantry stays asymmetric for too long
and that actually as we show here is
also happening or is also depending on
the phosphorylation of
myosin 11 f and k
and then lastly to be completely
physiologically relevant
you you have a process that also
involves spin proteins and that is when
you cut
a stem you actually cut it in a way that
you disrupt
the normal auxin flow then there's
actually a way for the plant to
recover from that and it will actually
make a channel
to overcome this defect and this channel
is
of this canalization hypothesis is all
based on the most predominant pin there
in the fluorescence stem which is pin
one so it's been one that starts guiding
this
um i don't visualize pin one here i
visualize uh secondary
uh balls so this is a
toluene blue stain that that visualized
the cell walls differently so
this is a real new channel because i had
cut this original transport mechanism of
the
of the stem in wildlife that happens
within
seven days but in my myosin mutant
within seven days i never see a fully
formed channel that connects back to the
tissue so there is again
something wrong with where the pins need
to be and how fast they meet where
they they are where they are supposed to
be so there's never fully connection
sometimes i i have lose individual cells
i never see anything that is connecting
like a wild type
i have the same thing happening in my
phospho-deficient mutants and it's even
stronger
this ones they don't even start
differentiating cells here so there's
not even a channel being
initiated when you have it in the
phosphodeficient mutant
so i also always have this wild type
supplemented
lines as controls to have the same
transgenic
control in there but then even more
importantly and that's why
auxin is known for it auxin has this
self-organizing
aspect of plant development which means
that when auxin accumulates somewhere
from there it will actually start
initiating vasculature that's what you
see in the leaves that's what you see in
the cotyledons that's what you see
in this setup as well so we again do the
same thing we cut the stem we disrupt
the vasculature so nothing is no oxygen
is coming from the top anymore
but what we do is we apply um in a drop
of vaseline so very
greasy thing we apply auxin and you
actually do see that there is
differentiation going on from this auxin
drop
to connect this to to the vasculature so
it's kind of that like the plant thinks
that this is a new but being formed and
it has to connect it to the vasculature
um
we cheated because we cut it first so um
but that's what is happening this is
also happening
in in when we supplement the plants with
the wild type versions of this myosin
mutant
and it's not happening anymore when we
when we have uh the phospho-deficient
mutants
so yes auxin canalization is also
impaired
and based on what i just showed you all
we really do think that this
auxin-induced myosin phosphorylation
is required for all developmental
processes that um
require this coordinated pin dependent
auxin transport
this is very very new as um people know
that is all
that auxin is affecting its own
transport but the mechanism by which was
not known yet so we
now would be among the first that
actually have a direct regulation
between
an actin binding a motor transport like
myosin
and vesicular trafficking with an effect
on pen transport
so to conclude i can only thank everyone
i've been working with
the list can never be too long i have a
very nice group
here she is of course my boss and we we
collaborate with quite some people for
fossil proteomics approaches
um like you like bert rebel in the in
the vip in ghent and then dolph and mark
and i would like to thank you for your
interest and maybe
by questions you get this aha moment
that was fantastic thank you inga
[Laughter]
and an excellent last slide um
so if people have questions you can
either put them in the chat and i'll
read them out or you can unmute yourself
um and i think you can answer them
and maybe i'll start i have a couple of
questions but the last few slides looked
a lot like grafting
um except for the the canalization
and the in the upper left the
um pin mediated um auxin
stream that gets reset up uh goes inward
in the stem
rather than outward so when we graft we
see vascularization
around the periphery of the stem do you
have any thoughts about that is that
simply because those cells are still
like uh simplistically connected and if
you were to sever it completely the
canalization would happen
externally or whatever exactly so
so what i do think indeed is that
because we don't
sever it completely we don't cut it
completely that we we don't force the
plant to be smart
so we don't force him to go outside so
we have this inner connection
possibility neat yeah we'll have to try
that we've never tried actually like a
half graft
it's a really cool idea um and then
i assume this is an open area of
research but how
how do you think myosin 11
phosphorylation is actually telling
myosin how to polarize and and
and how that sets up the polarity um of
the pins so what we are currently trying
and
and still failing at is to visualize
oxidant used polymerizations
changes or directional changes of myosin
fibers within
the plant because that would indeed
give us an answer or if we would see
auxin induced changes then
then that would tell us ah okay the
fibers go somewhere differently
or polymerize faster or slower which
would indeed
correlate with a slower vesicle
trafficking or different location
targeted trafficking that we sadly
enough don't know yet especially
not like how that would affect the
docking than
eventually of these spin proteins in a
different or the same way they
originally came from membrane structure
that we don't know yet soon
one day i love how it connects with the
gravatropic response and the
opposite responses and roots and shoots
very cool question
well does anyone else have questions
yeah margaret i have a i have a question
um yeah great great
talk um i was trying to keep a few
things in my mind during during the talk
and
um one thing i was thinking about is
kind of the physiological responses that
you're looking at with between ph
and root growth rate and
if i remember correctly it seemed like
the application of the the fusicosin
prevented the change in ph um
in the root apoplast but you also saw
the reduction
in the root growth rate so
i mean is that suggesting that
that the ph effects are are just happen
to occur
in parallel and that the auxin effects
are actually independent of ph
or maybe i maybe i missed something
oh okay yeah so what we do see is that
that by
activating the the proton pumps you
actually have a slight acidification
so the ph drops a little bit so that
that's this one here no it drops a lot
it doesn't it doesn't it's not to the
same level as normally the
the increase would be so the increase
would be double
as high but it drops a little bit by
this activation and the
the root growth does the opposite so you
enhance root growth
um so
[Music]
yeah no thank you that was i was just
trying to keep that in mind
i think i had the graphs flipped in my
head yeah
i went fast over there as well i'm sorry
no that's fine
um and then one one other question i had
was just thinking about the the confocal
setup
and i'm just curious if um
if you're using like ms media for
for that and if you know if if you guys
have done any sort of like chemistry of
it
because i know sometimes um sometimes
the iron key latent
and all that and the ms can yeah so we
we do use
ms media for this um
[Music]
but depending on what application we're
doing this for with
the chemistry of the ms medium so if we
are looking at anything calcium related
we do not put calcium ions in the ms
medium or we try to avoid to have too
many of them
if we do anything that that like if you
have chelation going on or if you change
something
phosphates very often start to crash out
of your ms which means the ph drops
immediately as well
so we try to keep it in mind and we try
to buffer everything we do as well
so every change we do we add it to the
medium but we keep
the medium buffered at our 5.8 um ph
um and we we try just to keep an eye on
it so that we don't overdo it but yeah
it's a half ms based medium
great thank you
yeah go ahead mrs harrison hi i'm maria
um
thanks for a great talk it was really
interesting i had a question about the
um effects on on cell expansion so
you've got this rapid growth and and the
wall loosening hypothesis but there
should be also an expansion of the
vacuole in the cells in the
expansion zone um and is that also
controlled by auxin
alterations yeah i can only talk about
the route because that's where i checked
it
um there we don't see it so we we don't
see that the vacuoler is actually
constricted then because it's inhibition
so it's the opposite effect
so we don't see it in the root cells
thank you and there's a question in the
chat
very cool research what could be the
proposed mechanisms that would lead to
proton influx in the root in such a
short time
frame by proton channels
proton channels but they're not known um
you have symport going on so for example
the ox-1
auxin importers symports two protons
with every oxygen molecule it takes in
so that could be a reason why we see it
so fast because auxin comes in and the
protons come in together with it
but um this mechanistic question is is
what is going to keep us busy for a bit
longer because
uh we don't know and there's potentially
linked with calcium influx and outflux
so
potassium is also probably related so
this is this is much more complicated
now the moment you start switching
iron responses you trigger turbo
responses and then you have
everything maybe triggering the other
thing
yeah complicated but you i think you've
gotten
you took a deep dive in figured out some
of the mechanisms
that's great um so i think we're over
time now
sorry about that um so let's thank inga
for a wonderful talk
thanks for wrapping up our seminar
series for the semester
um and i hope to see you in person
sometime
soon i'm available for students later if
needed
yeah great bye thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu